now i want to bring out one of the
hottest rappers in the game right now
his new album is called tickets to my
downfall which is pretty much the
greatest
album title ever and it drops tomorrow
let's say hello to machine gun kelly
everybody
[Music]
it is so nice to see see you i am such a
fan i've been like
totally like you're my spotify playlist
right now you've got such a cool sound
whoa i do i love it i love it i love
that you are pink and pearls
we could be friends i know so what do
people call you like
mgk or kelly or kell or
machine gun kelly i mean my friends
abbreviated call me kales but i'm kind
of haunted by this hair lady and from
this from nashville who called me kale
like the salad for oh that's and nobody
wants to be katie yeah and i was like
something so it was hard to to tell that
name to people so i mean my real name is
coulson
okay coulson okay i'll go well i don't
know machine and kelly kelly's awesome
maybe i'm just gonna say her full name
at the time yeah
i like all three really awkward um so
i'm whenever i'm writing um i definitely
put my
truth in my lyrics and that's usually
why i write um is because i need to get
something out
and i was looking at your lyrics and you
can be very poetic can i
ask you about some of them and kind of
where it came from okay so here's one
what is love love is pain love is
butterflies and stomach aches
love is looking out a window pane tears
dripping looking like you're in the rain
i mean that's so poetic thank you where
did that come from
i mean lyrics mean different things as
you as life continues i guess i mean
like i just found love for the first
time so
that that love was actually talking
about a family love that i was
that i that i didn't have and but but
now it kind of means to me that
loving someone is how much you're scared
to lose them wow
so the like how however that
amount is that you're scared to like
live this life without this person is
really how much you love them so
wow that is wow yeah i'm going to talk
about that in therapy next week so
um what so little big town that was
pretty awesome right i mean
you're from nashville you're country
singers you're storytellers that's
amazing
i mean exciting is what i meant to my
therapist out there
and here's here's another um i'm over
stimulated and i'm sad i don't expect
you to understand
i mean i feel like a lot of people
have felt like that like you know
because we're always constantly going
what does that mean to you like why'd
you write that
i mean probably what it meant to you
like when the world's eyes came on you
and people were wondering like you know
like well how could you be sad when all
of this opportunities come to you
and you know really it's like
uh the fact that you're over stimulated
it's like you have so much of
this these these things but they
they really don't equal out to emotional
support you know they're just like
materials yeah they're fleeting so um
and then the following line is i don't
expect you to understand because it's
almost like
i think jim carrey said it he was like i
wish everyone in the world could
experience what it's like to be rich and
famous just so you can realize that it
means nothing
yeah and it's in it coming from i like
if i was my poor kid self would be like
well try me
yo yo hey me too i said the same thing
dude
me too but i've been there that's what
i'm saying like i've been completely
dirt poor and and i would have made that
joke back then
but it is true like you really do and
coming back to your
you know the poetry with the whole
statement of love from you it's like
it doesn't equal out to that it doesn't
it's all fleeting
and unless you have like solid like
valuable
like worth in your relationships it's it
doesn't it's all going to go away like
it doesn't matter
um and that's coming from a kid that
came from nothing so
um but to switch the subject because i
feel like i've got you on the couch and
we're in therapy
but um you just want um yeah just lay
down
and let it all out machine gun kelly
so you just won um an mtv moon man at
the vmas
did did that mean a lot to you that was
so cool yeah
it was uh it was
most people get it on their first album
or second album or
third album or fourth album but it was
my fifth album that got me in the door
for the first time so i'm like really
you really earned that yeah dude i was
like it was this it was like this album
robust for me i was like should i just
give up on all those hopes and dreams
that i had like so i mean
i hope that there's someone who can just
uh use that as a metaphor for their life
that like
you know to continue manifesting and
never like stop chasing your personal
legend
because what a shame that would have
been if i would have turned my back
on this right before this happened and i
didn't even know that the light was on
was at the end of the tunnel like
right there you know i just would have
just turned around like ah that's like
five albums and would i really start
getting nominated at five albums
in yeah now just yes yes
so basically lesson here is yes um
and your new album i love the title
tickets to my downfall
that's amazing and it dropped that
that's just an amazing title
and it drops tomorrow so what does the
title mean to you
uh i use this example of like talking
about the goodyear blimp which
is probably floating around right now
and none of you have cared to
look at it because we see it every day
and it just exists but if it caught on
fire and started to
crash to the ground right now i'm sure
all of us would look up to the sky and
pull our phones out and
uh you know observe and appreciate
the sight that we're seeing which is
really an ugly sight it's like we only
cared about it because it's
burning and falling to the ground so
it's kind of like i felt like
i had more friends around me at the
worst time in my life
personally than i ever had when i was
succeeding or having a great time and i
was kind of like why is everyone
here for me crashing and burning like
why is everyone looking at me
during this time like this sucks yeah i
know i also feel like
unfortunately we're kind of those
people like just um humans we unless it
directly impacts
us you know it's like it almost doesn't
affect us and
we're fascinated by tragedy exactly yeah
unless it like it's it's hard to kind of
i don't know it's it's a hard thing to
to grasp especially when
everything's going wrong in 2020. not
just
it's gonna get better is what we're
saying we're so bright and shiny and
happy and smiling
um but tomorrow you're gonna be
performing
um on this show and what songs will you
be doing because you're doing kind of a
medley right yeah i'm doing
uh my ex's best friend as a song thank
you i'm super stoked on how that's doing
and then i since it's the album day
coming out and i wanted to do something
that we've never done on any anywhere or
i love that so it's called jawbreaker
yes something new as well i love that
tickets to my downfall drops tomorrow
y'all gotta go check it out it's so good
you